Fritzie finally found jared golf
apparently yep breaking news fritzy
finally found his man no necessary are
you sure it's Jared golf on these sounds
a lot like him and again I thought he
was coming out yesterday not his fault
not be ours fault
that was on me Oh as a miscommunication
he's right on time did you drive around
and hear that you were supposed to be on
yesterday Jared or did somebody tell you
yeah I'm here so yeah yesterday I was on
my phone in the morning so I come up on
Dan Patrick show yep but that's how
Fritzie books people apparently so he
just guilt you into yeah did you have
halloween last night at the house i did
not know i got home a little too late
and there's a bunch of trick-or-treating
going on but no I got home ate dinner
went to bed
when's the last time you put on a
costume couple days ago couple days ago
a whole Halloween party and I dressed up
as I was a Malibu's Most Wanted arrived
from Malibu his name which he may not
the bat was that I was I it was at a
talk really a little Halloween party for
us so we all dressed up most fun
who had the best costume man there was a
bunch of good ones in my opinion Tyler
Higbee our tight end it has his hair
please right now he was a catch he did
the whole thing the little strip on his
goatee little pleats strippers good I
love that let me give the formal
introduction he's Jared golf the Rams
quarterback they've got the Saints
coming up this weekend after the win
over the Packers I'm looking at some of
these quotes that you gave to Michael's
silver about Aaron Rodgers physically I
don't think it's even close he's the
best ever of just his arm talent what he
does I know Tom's incredible joe
Montana's amazing but when it comes to
straight physical ability and this is my
24 year old third year in the league
perspective so take it for what it you
will it's not even a contest
he is hand control arm power where he
puts the ball it's freakish Wow yeah
yeah and again like I said it's my you
know hangout oh boy a report but you
notice from what I've seen really and
he's incredible he's done a great job in
his career up to this point I was trying
to compete against in last week what did
you say to him after the game just you
know great game went on and moved on
well he could have been in a good mood
considering what happened with ty
Montgomery so do you take that into
consideration you know I think those
little postgame will handshakes is just
playing on a kind by you know respect
for what you guys did a good game you
know they've obviously had some stuff
going on there then but you know we're
lucky come away with that one is it
mandatory that the quarterback has to
say something to the other quarterback
at the end of the game I don't know I
just follow suit like that you know show
it to respect when it's when it's the
yard and you know like - there's
somebody's guys I'm friends with of
course and like to say hi and good job
is it like soccer do you guys exchange
jerseys at times at times that's what
happened before with you I don't I don't
love to do it on the field who've I seen
jerseys was um just guys I'm friends
with around the league
good exchangers okay Nick Vanette with
the Seahawks got buddies with have
exchanged with just buddies buddies are
I'm like I don't know if I've ever
exchanged quarterbacks question yeah but
what if Brees goes hey you want to you
want to change jerseys here exchange
jerseys here I might not have a choice
yeah I might just have to do my just
have to do right there right then in
there you know let me have your jersey
and your pants as well here on the field
here just standing there in your
jockstrap
you know and your pads I think that
would be good or do that do you you know
do that to him yeah yeah do you mind if
I get your jersey and your pants and
your helmet now did you get LeBron's
Jersey you and girly we did we did yes
okay what how did that happen that he
sends you his jersey
you know it was part of something they
were doing they call it the 23 and you
know me and Todd were lucky enough to be
chosen and I was awesome showed up in
our locker for one of the programs I
believe the preseason showed up in our
locker it was it was great
have you gone to a game yet I have I was
at the second home game they played the
Spurs they lost that game they lost in
overtime yeah it was fun it was good
what kind of football player do you
think LeBron would make man he'd be he'd
be pretty special I think put them put
them outside of receiver Eventide added
Dover jump balls and I think he'd have a
you know a pretty pretty easy time you
want to get it he said Jared Goff he's
got the Saints coming up in New Orleans
this weekend and what is it like when
you know the play is for Todd Gurley I
don't know if you can keep your
excitement level down but if you know
the ball is going to Todd Gurley and
maybe it's out of the backfield because
there are a couple of those plays but
what's that feeling like to have that
weapon yeah it's incredible I think
anytime the pitch you know you say when
we know it's kind of designed to go to
him and it doesn't happen a lot of times
it does end up you know pretty pretty
good for us and you know he's been
incredible this year and couldn't be you
know happier to have a guy next to me
like him and you know everything he does
not only physically but you know in
protection and how smart he is and I'm
gonna the teammate he is it just makes
my job that much easier when's the last
time you went to the line of scrimmage
and you said this is going to be a
touchdown across the middle where
everybody went left and then he went
back across yeah yep you got it so as
soon as you see it or do know it before
it was it was a play we checked too and
we got the coverage you wanted you may
kiss copper I could feeling about it
again like when her you can get the ball
on his hand in space you kind of had a
pretty good idea of what's gonna end up
happening and with that play and that
defense that was called it you know it
all came together
it's the when's the last time you were
hit in practice hit in practice man
like college a long time ago hopefully
not very often but can you imagine what
it's like for these quarterbacks that
have to go against your defense I mean
especially Oh defensive line yeah it's
you know you see it every day in
practice with our scout team and how
much trouble it gives that but yeah I
don't no doubt I think you know Aaron
and Jim brokers and Sue and now we've
added Dante and Sampson and Matt and all
the guys we have up front that can do
such special things and and Aaron being
that kind of you know cow and doing all
the stuff he's done this year it's been
incredible to watch and again it feed
off it on offense and helps me out so
much what is the biggest concern you
guys have on offense I don't know I
don't think we'd like to say we have any
concerns just trying to continue to keep
getting better and keep you know and
pushing the standard even higher every
day in practice and every week and just
try to you know hold hold ourselves to a
high standard and get better I also are
you watching the Thursday night game you
know I'll probably be here pretty late
but I'll probably saw ya do you even
yeah but it's it's the Niners and the
Raiders I mean that's tough to watch
Yeah right
oh I mean I don't really think I would
sit down to really put that put down a
few hours to watch any any game right
now but yeah I'll see it I'll see some
minutes passing by and see some plays
yeah but you're like your loyalty with
the Niners is long gone it's long gone
yes it's long gone when I got drafted
two years ago it went long out the door
but your Giants San Francisco Giants
loyalty is still there still there still
there okay but I know you're you're
asked if you might change your
allegiance there when you threw out the
first pitch at a Dodger game and you
said we'll see did I that's the quote I
got were you miss quoted you know I
don't remember those long time ago but
I've got I've got you know it's funny
because those la mr. O'Connor you know
there's a lot of that to it but you know
people I see guys for their home home
state home city team all the time
and publicly and they don't get pretty
cool and then everyone smiles like you
know say something about the Giants or
the Warriors girl what are you doing I'm
like no I'm from there come on break
well okay but you you threw out the
first pitch and you know that's that's
the problem you were in a Dodge yeah
okay so I'm you know of course I'm a
Giants fan from the bay but you know
when I'm not you know I guess hating the
Dodgers you know I'm rooting for them at
times too and definitely you know I know
some guys on the team want them to do
well but you're just a giant fan harder
okay I just want to make sure cuz you
know that they take this very very
serious very serious they do they do I
know it's hard for me I'm bringing the
group out in a couple of weeks bringing
we're bringing a whole whole posse out
there so you want to direct us to where
we need to go for a game no for
celebrities oh okay yeah sure I'll take
care of you guys but where do we go in
LA yeah man anywhere anywhere go down to
West Hollywood no how about Girly's
house can we go there sure yeah give it
to me right yeah okay here we go here's
Todd girlies and is it awful is it off
Sepulveda or La Cienega or yep it's
right there have fun safe travels and
good luck against the sink by the way
full disclosure I picked the Saints to
go to the Super Bowl okay okay I just
want you to know this will be my last I
want to show that I guess okay but you
know what I wanted to be honest with you
I did pick I did pick a Los Angeles team
to go to the Super Bowl but it wasn't on
forget I picked the Chargers that's okay
we still we still like you sorry all
right all right
I'm just I don't want to lie I don't
want to be phony you know I just I want
it all right right good luck against the
my Saints and thanks for joining us yeah
all right guys thank you for having me
appreciate it next year
go he plays for the Rams for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]